lead is up to 23 12 points in eight  minutes  wow so he makes a three and then takes a  charge and it just stay matched  uh they are tremendous and then the  anticipation defensively just  back to back plays kel kevin durant  welcome back so good to see you  yes steve nash jokingly telling us he's  waiting to see  which of his players will be sent into  orbit by zion when he puts his head down  [Music]  uh  the challenge is successful there is a  blocking foul on durant it is prior to  the gather  it is new orleans ball out of bounds  after the review  it's ruled a block on durant prior  to the gather durant doesn't seem to be  taking it too hard malika andrews to you  no  he it does not appear to be